a lot of private Equity firms entire
Playbook circles around going in buying
the assets firing everyone and then
putting those assets in another company
that is not our Playbook this is not to
say PE is evil it's just that they are
different business models it's a capital
Market you can do whatever you want the
way we wanted to approach it was simple
legal conversations not negotiation
keeping the founders involved after the
transaction allowing them to participate
meaningfully in all the upside that
we're going to create and not materially
changing the business or only doing that
if it's Last Resort and not Our
intention